there are around 8.4 million students in
Germany attending a total of thirty
three thousand five hundred schools
foreigners are often surprised to learn
that the German federal government
doesn't regulate the school system it's
up to education ministers in the
country's individual states to set the
curriculum and hire staff this
complicates the enforcement of uniform
guidelines nevertheless common standards
do exist all children must attend four
years of primary school after that
students enter high schools or secondary
schools after attending a secondary
school for six years they can opt for
vocational training this is organized
into a dual system that includes both
practical work at a company and
theoretical study in a vocational school
students who want to attend a university
have to finish eight years of a high
school completing a full twelve years of
school and all germany spends about 130
billion euros a year on education this
may sound like a lot but the figure puts
Germany in the bottom third of all oacd
countries it represents only 4.3 percent
of the country's GDP by comparison
Portugal spends 5.8 percent and Norway
spends 6.1 percent
you